So here's a proposal.
I'm going to give a point every time the
learner answers a question correctly.
>> That makes a lot of sense.
>> That means a lot of sense, so you
basically get credit for being right.
>> The learner gets credit.
>> The learner gets credit for
being right.
>> Okay.
>> I'm also going to give + 1 to the
teacher, and for the teacher, I'm also
going to give them credit plus one every
time the learner answers correctly.
>> Good, so
their incentives are aligned.
>> Yes, their incentives are aligned.
The learner gets credit for
demonstrating they've learned, and
the teacher gets credit for
demonstrating they
the least know something.
So, what do you think is
going to happen here?
>> That learner's happy
getting answers right, and
the teacher is happy when
the learner gets answers right.
So they should work
together to maximize,
I guess not necessarily learning,
but ask easy questions.
If you ask easy questions, then
the learner wins and the teacher wins.
>> That's exactly right, I think.
So hopefully it makes sense.
So if let's say this question or
questions way down here are so
easy that anybody can get them right.
Then if I ask questions down here,
the learner will get them right.
So it's good for the learner, but
also because the learner will get them
right that's good for the teacher.
>> Right, but that doesn't seem to
really make sense for this problem,
in that we really want to
be asking questions
roughly at the level
where the learner is.
>> Well, that makes sense.
But let me ask you one other quick,
before we get there,
let me ask you one other possibility.
Since this doesn't give us what we want,
right,
basically this says always
stick to easy questions.
>> Right.
>> And we'll both do well.
What happens if I say okay well
the problem here is I've incentivized
the learner in a way that
kind of makes sense, right,
learner wants to get a correct
answer to good questions, right.
But I've incentivized the teacher
to go easy on the student.
So why don't I make it so
that the teacher loses a point every
time the student gets something right.
>> So now,
the teacher is not incentivized
just to give easy questions.
What's going to happen here?
>> Well, part of me feels like that now,
it just seems like that the right
thing for the teacher to do then,
from the teacher's perspective,
is give hard questions.
The learner should try to answer them,
but learner's not going to
be able to answer.
>> Right, so what I should do is just
immediately go to all the really,
really hard questions about dinosaurs.
You can answer them.
You don't have the background and
the sort of fundamental math and
calculus to answer
the questions about dinosaurs.
And so you're going to keep
getting them wrong, but
the teacher is going to do just fine.
And in fact, not only will the teacher
lose a point every time the learner
answers something correctly.
Let's say actually,
the teacher gets a point every time
the learner answers incorrectly,
which is sort of the same thing.
>> Yeah.
>> But allows me to say
the teacher racks up points-
>> Yes.
>> By making you do
things that are wrong.
Okay?
So this is just kind of broken, right?
The kind of obvious thing to do here
where I'm going to give the student
credit for demonstrating thing,
demonstrating they've learned things,
they have knowledge.
And give the teacher credit for
either demonstrating that
the student has knowledge or doesn't
have knowledge, gives me bad answers,
and in particular, doesn't help
me with the goal of learning.
It doesn't help the student and
it doesn't help the teacher.
It just gives them whatever credit
they're supposed to get when they can
bother to get it.
>> So ok, if the teacher getting + 1 for
the learner getting something correctly
ended up making things too easy, and
a minus 1 made things too hard,
then right in the middle is a zero.
So what about the teacher get zero for
learner answering correctly.
>> Well, the teacher get zero for
the learner answering correctly,
then it doesn't matter
what the teacher does.
>> So, maybe the teacher
can do the right thing now.
>> But why?
It's just like the coco example you've
given before, what reason do I have.
And we certainly don't want this
to be the teachers high payment.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Although.
>> Would that work in this case?
No, because now that the learner would
want to get to maximize the side
payments, then we're back to
the original problem that you said.
Which is, if the teachers paid off for
the learner giving correct answers,
then the questions are just going to
end up being too easy to be meaningful.
>> That's right.
And there's really no side payment for
the teacher to give the student.
But you said something
earlier that I really like.
You said, what did you say,
you said something,
before he went down this path of the
minus one and getting hard questions,
you said something about what
the teacher ought to be doing.
>> The teacher ought to be asking
questions, I don't know, so
that the learners kind of
getting half of them right.
>> So I like that, so
let's sort of take a step back and
kind of see what that
would sort of mean.